[SPEAKER_00]: Second of Wealsun at 11.30 p.m., Gouge attempting to get back his spell slots is interrupted by Paul Rivero and Gouge.
[SPEAKER_00]: Jude trying to get back his spell slots is interrupted by Gouge and Paul Rivero.
[SPEAKER_00]: Wait, like interrupted as in I don't get the spell slots back?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, they come in.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, I try really hard to stay meditative.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Jude is in this very serene state.
[SPEAKER_00]: Paul would take, er, Jude would take by three in the morning to get all your spells off back.
[SPEAKER_03]: We're not doing that.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm still trying to card to concentrate anymore, though.
[SPEAKER_02]: Say I go up.
[SPEAKER_02]: And go, not worthy of an embrace, Jude, but you are more worthy than a handshake.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I reach out to...
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't have that in there.
[SPEAKER_02]: Whether you're what you're doing, grab them like this.
[SPEAKER_02]: Shit.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Fuck.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wait, what?
[SPEAKER_00]: I think we gotta get moving.
[SPEAKER_00]: What time is it?
[SPEAKER_00]: It's 11.
[SPEAKER_00]: 11.30.
[SPEAKER_01]: You didn't want to wait until like 1?
[SPEAKER_01]: I only had a couple more hours.
[SPEAKER_01]: What happened to the tower?
[SPEAKER_01]: Is it the west tower?
[SPEAKER_01]: Sub tower?
[SPEAKER_01]: Where we came from?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, not where you came from.
[SPEAKER_01]: We talked to the captain and he was going to move on the...
[SPEAKER_00]: He hasn't sent the attack yet.
[SPEAKER_03]: We haven't sent the attack yet.
[SPEAKER_00]: That was going to happen at 12.
[SPEAKER_03]: That was going to happen at 12.
[SPEAKER_03]: We haven't talked about it yet.
[SPEAKER_03]: I talked about the plans with them about going to the coastline or levitating over the wall into the sanctuary.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, we would still probably want to do that from the ocean side.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I can either levitate one or spider climb one.
[SPEAKER_01]: But right now, we're taking it to a boat.
[SPEAKER_03]: We're taking it to a boat.
[SPEAKER_03]: To what?
[SPEAKER_03]: To go now?
[SPEAKER_03]: To either go along the coastline and under the cavern into the helm or go over the wall.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, can your homunculus search for it?
[SPEAKER_01]: Because if I can have an hour to do a ritual spell, I can change my frog.
[SPEAKER_03]: The only problem is it's made out of clay, and it will.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I mean, that's not going to hurt you, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, but I don't want to lose my homunculus.
[SPEAKER_02]: Wasn't there another one?
[SPEAKER_02]: Weren't they saying going straight to the door of the tower and getting through it and going into the keep to...
[SPEAKER_02]: Through the front?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Through the front?
[SPEAKER_03]: I mean, that's almost suicide.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, no, no.
[SPEAKER_00]: So the plan was the diversion attack and then taking that wall to get into the tower.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right, but from the coastline.
[SPEAKER_00]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: The same place that you would search for the caverns as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: So if we're over there, can you use, I don't know, can your homunculus fly?
[SPEAKER_00]: Now the sergeant described that if you go up the wall, there is a way to get to the inner sanctum if you want to get the fairfield, the fairway.
[SPEAKER_01]: From going up the wall at that spot?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, because I'm going to the wall of the tower.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so we still down to two.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Look, quite frankly, I'm not surprised.
[SPEAKER_01]: I was kind of thinking that I wouldn't be able to get the slots back.
[SPEAKER_01]: Four hours was going to push it.
[SPEAKER_01]: I was hoping that you'd be here a little later.
[SPEAKER_01]: Any problems getting here?
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: Clears could be.
[SPEAKER_01]: What happened to the other 20 guys or 30 guys?
[SPEAKER_02]: We left them on there and they're... No, I mean the ones that fled.
[SPEAKER_02]: The ones that you didn't kill.
[SPEAKER_01]: The hobgoblins.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, they're still in the keep.
[SPEAKER_02]: They still have the keep and still have the lighthouse over there.
[SPEAKER_02]: We have the tower.
[SPEAKER_00]: They have the garrison.
[SPEAKER_02]: They have the garrison.
[SPEAKER_02]: We have the tower.
[SPEAKER_02]: We have a sergeant there who's going to signal all ships to stay away.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then they're watching the hobgoblins and we'll break on them if they start coming from behind.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so if we're going to move earlier, do we want to move into position and then have the captain forego the attack on the other lighthouse and demonstrate at the front gate?
[SPEAKER_01]: The demonstration was just to pull the guards away.
[SPEAKER_00]: Correct.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right, so just to pull the guards off of those side walls.
[SPEAKER_01]: The captain was going to take the tower first, and then while we moved into position, he was going to send 50 men to take the tower.
[SPEAKER_01]: When they were done and moved back, as long as they could take it easily, he was going to maneuver and demonstrate fires and assemble a battery.
[SPEAKER_01]: I didn't want him to waste troops.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I figured that would pull any of the garrison to the front gates, or the front walls, and we could maybe clear some of the passageways for us to get...
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, we're in a room alone.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, I don't know if Fairwind's good or bad, but I'm keeping from talking about this in front of the captain of the household guards.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I just told him he might be under some spell or something.
[SPEAKER_01]: So do you suspect that Lord Farrowin has given up the spell because of the sahuagin?
[SPEAKER_02]: No evidence, but suspicions are extremely high.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, I have suspicions too, but...
[SPEAKER_03]: There hasn't been any evidence to show.
[SPEAKER_01]: You didn't tell me you had suspicions.
[SPEAKER_03]: I had suspicions.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, I mean, yeah, we all suspect because he's the ranking.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, to be fair, we haven't actually had the time to talk about this.
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't... As soon as we dropped him at the beach, we started...
[SPEAKER_01]: I think he would have...
[SPEAKER_01]: Were you sent here to assassinate him?
[SPEAKER_02]: You were...
[SPEAKER_02]: Sorry.
[SPEAKER_02]: You or him?
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean him, not me.
[SPEAKER_01]: I assume you could have done that much easier.
[SPEAKER_01]: You could have done that much easier at Ferd's when I was sleeping.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, I'm actually trying to figure out what the hell's going on.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, okay, so we still need to, so can we take him alive?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, we will have to.
[SPEAKER_02]: What are we talking about?
[SPEAKER_02]: We're talking about if he's turned on us and this is a political fiasco and we're getting screwed, then we need to bring him back and have him as a political prisoner.
[SPEAKER_01]: And or he needs to tell us how to undo and re-institute the, like maybe he has to be tortured, but we have to get the Sahagin back.
[SPEAKER_01]: Away from the island.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, that's the first step.
[SPEAKER_01]: Get the Sahuagin away.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, why are they here?
[SPEAKER_02]: It's been centuries, so... That's the question.
[SPEAKER_03]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_03]: He should know.
[SPEAKER_03]: The only suspicion is because he kept them away, I guess, from some bullshit.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you have any knowledge of CLs operating in the area?
[SPEAKER_01]: Because I know they hate Sahuagin.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, but the ranger with me I'm sure does.
[SPEAKER_02]: He knows the island well and is well-versed of all of us.
[SPEAKER_01]: The only thing I can think of is maybe there was an agreement with the sea elves that maybe Lord Farrow one fucked up.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can't talk to those guys?
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't swim very well.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, I guess if they came up on land, I've never been to one of their domiciles.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think we need to get in and get to him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, let me get my shit together.
[SPEAKER_01]: I would still like to be able to search.
[SPEAKER_01]: Are you saying that you can or you can't?
[SPEAKER_01]: You want to go now, now wait an hour.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, my Mahamakui cannot fly.
[SPEAKER_03]: It glides.
[SPEAKER_03]: It can fly.
[SPEAKER_03]: No, you said it glides.
[SPEAKER_03]: But, I mean, it could climb the wall.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's what I was saying to him.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so it could search the coastline.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, it'll search the coastline.
[SPEAKER_02]: Me and the ranger can scout out ahead.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: And make sure everything's clear.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: How do you want to travel?
[SPEAKER_01]: The island's a little barren.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know if they're going to have any watches on that side.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you guys have a plan to do so in stealth?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: We are, honey.
[SPEAKER_00]: Don't worry.
[SPEAKER_00]: We're on our way.
[SPEAKER_00]: Who said that?
[SPEAKER_00]: There's a woman in this barracks?
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: The winches.
[SPEAKER_01]: Give me 15 minutes to get my supplies and shit ready.
[SPEAKER_01]: I can meet you at the front gate.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I think we're going to stay off of, we're going to be as close to the coastline as we can, stay with whatever cover there is.
[SPEAKER_02]: The ranger can throw up some fog, worst case of... Are we allowed to do black face?
[SPEAKER_02]: Black face, too.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, of course, red face.
[SPEAKER_02]: I haven't seen the disguises yet.
[SPEAKER_03]: They sound interesting.
[SPEAKER_03]: Am I allowed to put my bad mask on, then?
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't think you're going to need it here, but I mean, if you can operate with it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Anyways, to the DMs, so does that mean that I still only have the original three points back, three spell slots back, not the full?
[SPEAKER_01]: Is that how we described it?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, we're shiny at first, the one you have on now.
[SPEAKER_03]: Right now I have metal.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you can't really see much, but everything's super tight and gloves.
[SPEAKER_02]: Describe my character.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, I mean, we're looking at you, I'm like...
[SPEAKER_02]: I can't cure leprosy, but somebody probably can.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think you've already beat it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Isn't that why we went to Hempoland?
[SPEAKER_01]: For you to beat the leprosy?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: It sure is.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right.
All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll go get the crew.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let me get my components.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll be with them.
[SPEAKER_03]: We'll talk a little bit about what we, the other planet, and we'll wait for you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Make it quick.
[SPEAKER_01]: Five minutes, ten.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ten tops.